good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day I am
because out of all this podcast studios
in all the world you decided to walk
into mine hey Ben my co-host for today
how you doing I'm doing great how are
you doing thank you so much for being
here on show notice show
I'm having a stroke short notice Jax was
unavailable today and I thought hmm I
have so many options for co-hosts down
here Olivia she was child rearing so she
was not available while you were my only
choice you were also my first choice
also as we discussed on the patreon I
really have come into my own as a
podcaster since I now have basically an
award-winning podcast that had Hilary
Duff on it that like blew up the
internet too yeah so honestly I am like
should be your first choice
um and you can take that Taylor Striker
I feel I feel like this is the first
time that you have been on the toast
proper since you were in People magazine
and we actually have a lot of stories
today from People magazine you know it's
a it's a critically acclaimed
journalistic Beacon
um how does that feel how do you feel
like you've changed as a podcast host
since being on People magazine I mean
it's also the first time that I've been
on the toast since being deemed a proper
celebrity by myself oh yeah we spoke
about it on patreon but right so I am
like a celebrity female
um People magazine yeah CEO CEO founder
Society yeah use code toast if people
are looking for Ben to answer for a lot
of what we've been talking about on the
potosa last couple of weeks you know
beans celebrity passport we did a whole
hour-long patreon um last week Ben
joined me and we talked we talked
through it I feel like we're in a better
place now do you agree yeah it was like
really Judge Judy
um we both judged each other and then at
the end we came to decide that uh some
of the stuff I was wrong for
yeah you didn't admit to any of your
faults what was I wrong for uh we we
discussed that potentially the way that
you dragged out the flashlight uh gate
was was a bit harsh given Theo's
condition but again no spoilers go and
sign up for patreon so you can listen
we're not doing it here I also don't
feel like it's healthy for us to rehash
you know we've moved past it we've
rehashed are you excited to hop on the
toast I feel like something so
underrated about you that I think I was
just telling Jackie is you like low-key
are not like really at all caught up on
like pop culture no I live in my own
world in my own bubble and when I do get
like just a little piece of info
um I like run with it right and one of
the stories today that I chose
specifically for you is all about
Caitlyn Clark oh great because I know
that's actually something you weirdly
like fell into a rabbit hole on and you
have become quite taken with yeah I mean
we spoke about this yesterday hi Bruno
oh Bruno just showing us we spoke about
this yesterday
for those of you that don't know Caitlyn
Clark she is the star of Iowa women's
basketball I just read that college yeah
by the way there is no Iowa women's WNBA
team by the way why the [__] would I
know that I don't know
so true
uh apparently the national championship
game last night got like the most views
in the history of uh people watched it
nine million more than most NBA games
this year Major League Soccer yeah like
like big time numbers and it's all
because of Caitlyn Clark this girl from
Iowa is like unbelievable and it's like
the first time that people actually give
a [__] about women's sports and is huge
for women's sports because not only is
she good but the new nil rules I don't
know if you're familiar with them but
this is the first year where women or
like college athletes College athletes
get to get paid so she made like a
million bucks already and so like all
the chatter is Caitlyn Clark is so big
in college why the [__] would you go to
the WNBA to make peanuts she can stay in
college be the face of March Madness
bring in all this cash and all of a
sudden it's like a legitimate career for
her over a couple because she's three
more years of Eligibility right no and
then what you and I were saying was like
honestly if she's that great she should
be able to audition for the NBA like she
should it should be a meritocracy I'm
sure she's better than some of the
scrubs who sit on the bench yeah
probably not but like it's possible
probably not you think you know like we
can see like I I don't I don't know like
it's always hard when you're not playing
against your competition to truly know
how you'd play against other
competitions right right like it looks
like she would be like and maybe she
would be I just we just don't know we
just don't know um but back to what I
was saying I found Caitlin Clark on Tick
Tock yes and just like Tick Tock the way
that it builds stands yeah is is amazing
I saw her and then all of a sudden I'm
like when is the national championship
game I gotta watch her yeah and all of a
sudden we're in the car in Florida
coming from our beautiful vacation
coming to Jackie's house and uh I looked
and they were down 20. and then they got
blown out so my one day of being Caitlin
Clark fan uh I force them to lose but we
have an interesting story because
there's like more drama after the game
so we'll talk about that it's our fifth
and final
um teaser because you know it's it's an
important story but it's still women's
sports so it goes to the fifth and Final
um but thank you for joining me here
today I appreciate you being here and
I'm excited to get your tea
um on some of the stories I tried to of
course tailor the stories a little bit
to you but they're it's unavoidable so
I'll explain everything you know cool
cool can we talk about Training Day oh
my God okay you guys one thing about Ben
is like when I met him
and and still to this day Ben has like
never seen any movie that's like popular
or legendary he hadn't seen The
Godfather he hadn't seen my cousin
Vinnie and he's watched those two since
then but Ben recently has been watching
like other really well-known really
popular films acting he is not stopped
talking about training day acting like
he's the first person to ever see this
movie I mean it's just like you watch
these like dumbass shows like the Oscars
and you're watching these movies that
[__] suck like training day should
win today because somebody can watch it
today and Denzel should be awarded best
actor again because the movie is that
good and I just don't care about these
noobs like it the movies are just no
good I just like I don't see like what
about Leonardo Dicaprio and blood
diamond like why is nobody talking about
that Ben also recently just saw blood
diamond for the first time can you find
that scene where they were shooting up
the kids with drugs to be so chilling I
never forgot it I did find a chilling
which is why that kid should win best
supporting actor in this year's Oscars
as opposed to that [__] movie that
won for VR like 900 Awards what was that
everything everywhere all at once yeah
oh speaking of which this the star
what's her name from Michelle yo I just
watched her in Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
which which was amazing and she should
have won best actress in that Ben is
like 10 years delayed on films have you
ever seen I'm like that person what was
that story where that girl was hidden in
the bunker like is that Kimmy Schmidt
yeah
good story sorry that show
Kimmy Schmidt like was like Loosely
based off like some actual mole woman
yeah so I'm not I'm like stuck in 2000
I'm watching all like the the new movies
also my taste in music then the way you
are stuck in the 2000s with your movies
and music is the way I'm stuck in like
the early 2000s in terms of basketball
totally yeah like when I was in the like
11th grade I like really was into the
Knicks for approximately two years and I
knew everything like I was obsessed I
knew all the players that would go to
the games I would like watching
everything and then like I slowly
stopped caring so whenever me and Ben go
to Nick games like my reference point in
terms of data on the Knicks is Tyson
Chandler Raymond Felton Melo you know
three to the Dome bro three to the Dome
yeah and they have all retired so
they're no longer they're younger
they're no longer in the league yarmir
Jager that's a ranger yeah Ranger goalie
yeah good times good times I'm
what do you saying sure to the fast five
stories that you yes you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
stamps.com when every person moment and
penny counts in your business you can't
afford to take any of them for granted
stamps.com gets it because for the last
25 years they've been helping businesses
Like Yours save time and money so you
can focus on your business
knowingstamps.com has all your postage
needs covered with premium discounts and
great rates so it's the post office but
in your office because with stamps.com
all you need is a computer and a printer
they even send you a free scale so
you'll have everything you need to get
started and you know Jackson Claude love
a service that helps you stay at home if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through the stamps.com
dashboard running a business isn't cheap
especially when it comes to fulfilling
orders for your customers luckily
stamps.com has a huge carrier discounts
up to 84 off USPS and UPS rates plus
stamps.com automatically tells you the
cheapest and fasting fastest shipping
options for you your postage partner for
the last 25 years is Samsung com because
they have been an indispensable resource
for over a million businesses you're
getting access to the USPS and UPS
services that you need right from your
computer anytime day or night there's no
lines there's no traffic and there's no
waiting so so set your business up for
Success when you get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code toast for a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale there
are no long-term commitments or
contracts again just go to stamps.com
Click the microphone at the top of the
home page and enter code toast that is
code toast t-o-a-s-t
today's episode is also brought to you
by
[Music]
thumba that's right the bed by fuma
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood the bed has a
modern minimalist design that helps
Elevate any space and those spaces can
include snitches room in Jackie's house
yes Jackie's guest bedroom we now refer
to as snitches place has a thumabed it
is gorgeous snitch loves it we love it
because it was so easy to set up it came
in three easy to maneuver boxes and it
took around five minutes the bed itself
is super supportive for your mattress
it's breathable and it's made to
naturally minimize noise and create
space the bed is put together using the
Timeless technique of Japanese joinery
each piece locks into place meaning no
tools or excess Hardware are required to
assemble with clean lines subtle curves
and lifestyle enhancing details the bed
is simple sophistication for your
bedroom it's made for how you live so
it's backed with a lifetime warranty it
ships right to your door in three easy
to maneuver boxes and it takes about
five minutes to assemble again with no
tools required also thuma offers other
Essentials in addition to the bed they
have the mattress the nightstand and the
side table they'll perfectly complement
the bed they also have financing options
available create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma and now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
in the continental US go to thuma.co
toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash
toast for a 25 credit
oh wait way to like not support our show
you don't know anything no we don't do
the crunch anymore and by the way I
support do you know how inundated my
tech talk is with Clips
or my reels like you guys are popping
off on the social platforms I feel like
I don't even need to tune into the show
well you don't so cool and maybe you do
need to tune into the show or else you
would know that we don't do the crunch
maybe if you had a business that you
wanted did you decide to remove this
because we're not the wait why did we
decide to remove the crunch because the
first five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your toast your morning toast yeah I
think it was because like our remote
setup didn't really
um allow that sort of special effect
but like you could just use like a
pre-recorded me
we could if we wanted to nauseate people
and we don't because the toast seeks to
heal okay all right our first story
which I did choose specifically for you
because it's about Judaism and one thing
about you is that you can find really
any route to end up talking about
Judaism and there's a person in this
story who I've been told so many times
that you look like have you heard about
this no but I'm sure I'm gonna hate it
no no he's cute so Sophia Richie Lionel
Richie's daughter Nicole Richie's sister
is converting to Judaism ahead of her
wedding to Elliot Grange and Elliott
Grange actually looks a lot like you Ben
let me show you a picture I mean he just
is like a brunette and wears glasses and
kind of has like a actually he really
doesn't look like you but he just has
your glasses it's literally you
literally do stand up on this and talk
about beanie feldstein and you are
literally doing this to me no he's like
oh does every brunette that has glasses
and by the way I am like sorry much more
handsome than that I couldn't you put 40
pounds on that man
he's not good looking anymore 40.
oh my God okay I'm totally kidding ten
yeah
um so she's converting to Judaism and
like nobody knew I mean everyone knew
she was getting married she has a huge
engagement ring and it was all really
cute and then she posted yesterday on
Instagram a picture of her sitting at a
desk in what appears to be a shul or
synagogue of some sorts because there's
a stained glass window behind her and
she's sitting in front of some sort of
scripture and she wrote what a magical
day I want to thank Nate uh thank Cantor
Nathan lamb for helping me along this
journey of converting to Judaism it has
been one of the greatest experiences of
my life today was that day with five
Jewish star emojis wow is that nice
unbelievable we need we need more juice
we need more cool Jews yeah we do and
Jews who like are open to posting about
their Judaism online I find so many
celebrities who are Jewish I can never
talk about it it's almost like they're
ashamed and the best part like some
people are like weird about conversion I
absolutely love converted Jews because I
think that they just take Judaism so
much more seriously yeah than 99.9 of
people that were born into being Jews
who just said oh I went to Hebrew school
once so like I'm good or I have like a
roast on the holiday so I'm good like
they learn truly what it means to be
Jewish it's honestly probably like such
a cool experience to like learn all
about the customs and stuff when you're
old enough to appreciate it it was just
kind of like we were learning it so
young we didn't really understand like a
lot of the meaning and so I think that's
why so many people who convert end up
being like more devout and more
religious than people who were born
Jewish because you have like a a
different appreciation for it I see a
business
but you want to be you know you're not
allowed to proselytize no no not not
conversion but maybe it's like a course
uh for older Jews that are looking to
get into it where we can charge money
and because we're like a religious
institution we could also like make a
shul and not pay taxes yeah I'm so down
to not pay taxes so the daughter of
Lionel Richie was race Christian and she
attended Oaks Christian School in West
Side village for a few years she's
openly discussed the importance of her
faith and now she's joining ours this is
a good one so if you ever she's so cool
I completely forgot that she was Lionel
Richie's daughter and you know I am
Lionel's number one fan hello isn't me
you're looking for that was so keep
going yeah that was good I can see it in
your eyes I can see it in your smile
you're part of like the one percent of
people our age who hear Hello and don't
think of Adele no Lionel yeah I know and
if you've seen that music video it's
incredibly controversial oh yeah it's
just like about some blind girl who like
like puts your hands out like can't see
anything it's like hello oh it's like
talking to a blind girl they're saying
it's ableist is that what they're saying
no it's just like weird that is
definitely it's just like a strange and
like I'm 100 sure that Lionel did not
cast a blind girl to play the blind girl
no you think he had nothing to do with
the casting no it's it's just like
remembering Glee who was the kid who was
in a wheelchair oh oh already okay so
you're saying that you don't think the
girl in the music video was actually
blind in real life no I just don't think
that there are many blind actresses but
there but there are enough that she
could have been cast yeah no it's not
like you can find a blind actress I
don't know if there's like many many
famous ones but you're right about that
guy in Glee Kevin McHale who played Arty
was not a paraplegic also fun fact about
Kevin McCall Kevin McHale is a very
famous basketball coach not really but
like like really famous not already a
guy named Kevin McHale oh that's also
Arty's name yeah tough for Artie like in
Google SEO he'll just never pop up that
you know is also a problem for Brian
Kelly the Points Guy yeah yes there's a
very very famous football coach for
Notre Dame yeah Brian Kelly very famous
and I feel like I'm always saying the
story one half of the former band known
as Florida Georgia Line is also named
Brian Kelly oh I did not know that Tyler
Hubbard and Brian Kelly if I had to bet
I bet that our Brian Kelly will
eventually surpass the other other Brian
Kelly's in their notoriety on Google
well Brian Kelly
from Florida Georgia Line spells it
differently and the band is now defunct
he's still acting he's still working
he's a why I think it's
k-e-l-l-e-y oh but he's he's a brain
yeah I just feel like anybody like in
country music you're immediately Brian
Brian
right you're not Brian you're Brian well
phonetically yes you are Brian Brian
um so Nicole Richie I mean uh Sophia
Richie's joining the faith and I for one
am thrilled thrilled thrilled yeah it's
amazing we gotta convert Lionel maybe
he'll be so taken by his daughter's you
know Journey that he'll be so inspired
himself to then write a song shalom
shalom
is it God you're looking for oh my God
and then he'll start converting other
people with the rewrite of this song yes
it's getting very weird Al no it's yeah
by the way weirdo let's go off on so
many tangents it's okay go this is why
you're here Weird Al unbelievable do you
think you're Weird Al Yankovic's number
one fan uh no Matt hardun is Weird Al
Yankovic
but uh I'm a big fan I think it's just
the way that he parodied complicated
into constipated and the way that he
parodied uh riding dirty to white and
nerdy and that's really like you too or
Gangster's Paradise to Amish Paradise I
mean he's a true Visionary I actually
think that Jackie would really enjoy his
work you know you and I were actually
weirdly talking about Weird Al before
bed like three nights ago um and we were
trying to guess what his net worth was
yeah it's too low yeah but like he
basically just made like YouTube videos
you know he was before his time if he if
he existed now Tick Tock oh he'd be the
bee's knees yeah that's actually true
all right ready for our next story I'm
ready Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny are
cuddling up while sharing a horse on a
romantic date sharing a [__] a horse so
Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny have taken
their romance to The Stables the duo
shared a horse while on a date on the
Hidden Hills equestrian center on Sunday
in photos obtained by PMZ Kardashian sat
up front and the singer was holding on
tight from behind she dressed he dressed
casually for the weekend in a tan jacket
and black pants so this is revolutionary
for a multitude of reasons but mostly
because we never really have gotten
confirmation on whether these two were
dating they were spotted leaving
somewhere going to the same place but
not actually like a photo and this is
pretty much like a confirmation and the
Bad Bunny fans especially a lot of our
Hispanic toasters are not happy about
this like they are very anti I think
because they really see themselves as
the perfect woman for bad money and they
don't think like Kendall really can
truly understand the man that is Bad
Bunny
yeah I also I'm sure that you've seen
the comparative photos but
Devin Booker and Bad Bunny are the same
person oh you think they look alike
identical oh really I never thought of
that yeah look up the two of them they
are they look the same I actually don't
think so okay I feel like that Bunny's
way taller Google Bad Bunny Devin Booker
comparison photo and you'll get a side
by side they look so similar they like
actually look nothing alike but I
respect your your bad call okay I mean
are you blind like the woman in hello
[Music]
that's a good one um they look a lot
alike but I would be pissed if I was a
bad bunny fan which it's not that I'm
Not A Bad Bunny fan I just have not
you're still listening to music from
2000 exactly I'll catch him when I'm
like 60.
um literally but uh the Kardashians have
had trouble with their men and keeping
them sane so the fans are probably just
maybe worried that bad bunny will go
down
the Kardashian curse not that it's real
maybe it's just a coincidence that's a
fair assumption I didn't want to I knew
you wouldn't care about this story but
it did give me the opportunity to ask a
question if you could date any
Kardashian like who do you think is the
prettiest like who do you who are you
most attracted to in a hypothetical
sense because I know you're not
attracted to anyone but Theo I'm not
attracted to anybody
um
Kylie 100 really yeah like 200 percent I
think
you were gonna say but like
okay like now I hate Kylie um continue
like why Kylie I don't know I think that
she's just like the most pretty and semi
like
I don't want to say anything mean no I
don't want you to say mean no no are you
talking about her face or her body no
she did well we're not getting into
specifics here
but she just she just looks like the
most like a regular a regular person to
me I feel like people would say that
Kendall looks like the most that just
because she hasn't had work doesn't mean
that she's like the most relatable like
Kendall is still like I look at her I'm
like oh my God like this is an enormous
like I just want to say it's all in the
future when you get asked this question
and you answer Kylie your answer would
be because she looks most like my wife
but it's almost like my life that's what
I said
no but in the future if you find
yourself in a situation like oh who
would you rather you know Alessandra you
look the most like Kylie of all of them
would you not say no I don't think I
would say that do you think you look the
most like probably Rob oh
yeah I mean that's not true see like
whenever people ask my celebrity crush I
always say John Mayer and they're like
oh really why am I because he looks like
Ben that's just not true you've also
said that about no I'm not saying it's
not true that I look like John Mayer
because maybe I do maybe I don't uh I
also apparently according to the
toasters look like John Favreau so it
depends on it depends on the day at
which you get asked that question no I'm
just saying like for future Revenue
you've also mentioned Harry Styles no I
have not really you've never spoken
emotionally about Harry Styles or
romantically romantically no emotionally
probably like that's what I do for a
living I mean you're literally lying no
I'm literally not I've seen the clips I
have the read receipts no the clip that
you're referring to is when we were
talking about who we would be rather
hypothetically sleep with yeah I've
never even asked any question like that
nor would I ever answer it I want to
sleep with my wife you didn't ask me who
do I want to sleep with actually that's
not what we said we said who we want to
settle down with even worse okay
sleeping with is a one-time thing
settling down is a whole lifetime I'm
gonna have to start blocking you from
the toes so you don't see our Clips
because you're a really toxic you're
kind of one of those toxic toasters no
you guys are toxic I see the clips
everybody's so mean to me
okay you're toxic okay you're toxic
because you're the one taking Clips out
of context yeah sure you clip them we
didn't even talk why don't you give
context and what you clip you control
what you click the whole point is just
supposed to be
attention to the whole episode but if
you just listen to the clips you are
digesting information with our context
thus giving you toxic thoughts and
leanings interesting you have toxic
thoughts and leanings interesting
So Bad Bunny and Kendall Jenner are
probably dating and I'm fine with it a
lot of people are not but like I am okay
with it how much weight can a horse hold
I guess between the two of them though
they probably still weigh less than Moon
Yeah and I've been on a horse have
anybody's seen that Majestic photo of me
at Brian's Ranch well the thing about
Brian is Brian's oh true Brian yeah
Brian has huge horses because Brian's
almost seven feet tall what no those
horses are dinosaurs yeah he has really
big horses and so when we go horseback
riding Eugenio who runs the horse farm
he knows which horses to put you on
which horses put me on my horse so that
we have you know different horses can
hold different ways true okay are you
ready for our next story I am have you
been following at all Vanderpump Rules
you know what's going on I watched the
one episode with you where I'm so sorry
to keep bringing this up but Lala was so
mean like I just watched it I'm like
this like how mean are you like what
kind of karma is coming back to you for
how mean you are to this poor girl so we
talked about this on the patreon and I
don't want to be repetitive but let me
just give some backstory Ben watched one
episode when they were in Vegas the
episode of Raquel had a panic attack and
then they were attacking her at dinner
the havasui episode have us like Havasu
um and Ben knew what was going on in in
the culture and in the context of the
affair and everything but he was solely
focused on Lala
yeah okay so that's this is the story
ready Ariana Maddox is wearing the
ultimate skin bearing Revenge dress for
the Vanderpump Rules reunion so the
reunion was filmed maybe like a week ago
and we just are now getting pictures of
everyone's outfits it was all kept
really under wraps and I think everybody
wanted to see you know this is the first
time Ariana is seeing her X-Men with his
new friend girlfriend which is literally
your ex-best friend and you know you
want a stunt you want to look and she
looks let me show you a picture and you
could say she looks beautiful I won't be
offended she looks amazing the dress the
hair look I'm showing Ben a picture
beautiful like sexy like she looks great
yeah so everyone was shook the house
down because
I don't know what we were expecting her
to look
but honestly it was better than I had
even imagined so the upcoming Vanderpump
Rules reunion is bound to be the most
dramatic one in shows history earlier
this year the news broke that longtime
couple and VPR co-stars Tom and Ariana
have called to quits after the TomTom
co-owner cheated with their co-star
Raquel Levis so last night Maddox really
kind of broke the internet because
revenge is a dish best served cold
Maddox is bringing her inner ice queen
out with her red hot reunion dress for
the upcoming drama-filled episode Maddox
is on fire in her skin tight cut out red
dress the head turning looks the head
turning look shows off her toned
physique with only two pieces of fabric
covering part of her chest and her ABS
she finished up the look with an exact
matching manicure and stacks of silver
rings and pin straight hair to add to
the sultry drama so I think everyone was
like really it's always exciting to see
what people wear to the reunion but this
is like a much more high-stakes reunion
especially for Ariana she looks amazing
I mean this dress is so hot her body
looks incredible her Glam is everything
and she just looks
she just looks amazing and I'm so happy
for her and everyone is really
everyone's just rooting for Ariana and
it's so exciting to be on the same team
as everyone for once because I find that
when Jax and I are on the toast we're
always giving our thoughts on like pop
culture things and everyone's always
like team this or team that we are
always on the unpopular team so it's
nice to be on the popular team yeah but
you're also never on the cheating team
no no there's not there's only one team
to be on correct that's the thing that's
what Jackie's always saying it's like
there can't be anybody on the other team
but everyone's watching Fidelity
everyone's walking around I'm like do
you still call it infidelity everyone's
like walking around in like team Ariana
shirts and it's like well okay like what
other team is there there's literally no
other team no other team no do you still
call it infidelity when you're not
married yeah yeah infidelity I don't
think is restricted to marriage I think
it's restricted to like monogamy cool
yeah but they were like in a 10-year
like domestic partnership I thought they
were married well that was like a big
point of contention and honestly I feel
like it's
they should break up obviously because
he's having an affair but they should
have broken up a long time ago because
like he very much like wants more of a
traditional marriage kid and like she's
been very clear from the beginning that
she doesn't want either of those things
and I feel like those are two things
like you really can't
those are deal breakers those are huge
things in a relationship he's mentioned
that he wants marriage and kids yeah
yeah cheats right that doesn't make any
sense if anything she should be the one
cheating right because she doesn't want
to get married right but instead it was
him yeah it's really it's all a hoax and
over the weekend she was out of town
they share a house together still yeah
well I don't know what their living
situation is but she's been living there
and he is not
um but she went out of town and he went
to the house and Raquel came over she
was spotted by Paparazzi um bringing
like a suitcase inside
is that correct this was recent no like
a couple days ago oh my God disgusting
right go to a hotel no it's are you so
cheap it's so disgusting well and he's
cheap because he has all these dumb
business ideas like starting a band that
he has to pay he literally pays like 20
people to be in his band he's pay them
like a thousand dollars a day to start a
band to start two restaurants one of
them in a strip mall like of course he
can't stay at a hotel he is definitely
has no money I think he is I think he
has points or a friend's house and a lot
of the money that he makes
um they put into this house together
doesn't Raquel have a house right I
don't know why they couldn't go to
Raquel's place that's a good call
seems like they're doing a lot like I
also thought this when it was happening
like Vanderpump was not very popular
it just seemed like the show could
really use a bit of a scandal I mean of
course the show was headed for you know
maybe a couple Seasons left they had
tried to shake it up they had fired
people and this all of a sudden put a
fire back under it and that would make
it it's a little too obvious like
everybody's talking about you but
you have a like do you think it's staged
that may I didn't that makes me think
it's staged Lisa or something is staged
there were rumors circulating that Lisa
Vanderpump and like Andy paid Raquel
they have spoken directly to like press
and and on Twitter and stuff I mean like
it's absolutely not true like they can't
believe this is going on but when you
when you know the history of the show
it's like not that crazy the show blew
up because in the first season Jackson's
dossey were like this couple everyone
loved them like it girl you know and
turns out the whole time Jax was
sleeping with Kristen Dodie like this is
what this group of friends does like
they all sleep together they betray each
other to like the ends of the Earth and
then they go back to being friends it's
such a [__] up Dynamic so if something
like this happening like it's entirely
possible but if you know the history
yeah
seems convenient yeah this story is very
strange I know
but Ariana looked amazing I'm so happy
for her and I cannot wait to see the
reunion I'm sure it'll be three parts I
also read online that we have 14 more
episodes in the season before the
reunion which you know before this had
happened yeah that would have made sense
like we've only seen a couple episodes
but you have to wait 14 episodes like
see something actually happen that'd be
so annoying that's more than three
months
today's episode is brought to you by
Thrive cosmetics and I'm really excited
that we are working with Thrive
Cosmetics because I've been using a lot
of their products for many many months
now thanks to you guys the toaster is
recommended to me when I was complaining
about um not finding the right mascara
for my eyelashes they're really really
straight and so many of you recommended
the liquid lash extensions mascara from
Thrive cosmetics and that's how I found
the brand and fell in love with them it
has 25 000 5 Star reviews that mascara
and it mimics the look of lash
extensions it really works they use a
proprietary tubing formula and that
basically means that it wraps around
each of your lashes as you apply it so
it'll dramatically lengthen and Define
your lashes from root to tip I can say
totally honestly this is the best
mascara I've ever used I use it every
day on the toast now I've had such
success with it and then that's how I
fell in love with the brand I love their
hydrating lip tints I know Jackie does
too we're always wearing them on the
toast it hydrates your lips but it also
offers that hint of color and that color
lasts up to six hours it applies super
evenly that for the application is
effortless and you actually don't even
need a mirror to put it on which is so
great um they have great eyeliner liners
highlighting sticks for the for the eyes
it's really a great brand and what we
love about the brand is it's Cosmetics
so causes in the name for a reason as a
part of their mission every purchase
supports organizations that help
communities Thrive so that's like those
battling with domestic abuse
homelessness cancer more more things
like that so you have to try Thrive
Cosmetics to really see for yourself and
right now you can get an exclusive 15
off your first order when you visit
thrivecosmetics.com toast that's Thrive
Cosmetics
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s.com slash toast
for 15 off your first order
today's episode is brought to you by
Honey Love shapewear so the reviews are
in Honey Love came out on top for best
wedding day shapewear with wedding
season upon us this is the ad you've
been waiting for whether you're a bride
a guest or you're just looking for an
everyday fit Honey Love Is Your go-to
for all things shapewear they have
revolutionalized compression technology
so you no longer have to feel like
you're suffocating while wearing
effective shapewear you'll immediately
feel and see the difference and of
course we have an exclusive offer for
our listeners you can get 20 off your
entire order with our exclusive link
honeylove.com toast again that's
honeylove.com forward slash toast I have
been wearing shapewear my whole life
different types of shapewear I feel like
I've tried so many different brands and
I found honey love years ago actually I
think through like a Facebook ad and I
bought it immediately and it is the only
shapewear I wear every time I'm on stage
I've worn them on stage when I go to
events weddings family outings anything
I love the super power short it helps
sculpt and smooth from stomach to thigh
and it offers just the right amount of
compression so it really holds you in
and Smooths everything out but you can
breathe and that is such a delight they
also have body suits with 360 degree
bonded compression that Smooths your
tummy and hips it has built-in bust
support and it lifts without underwire
so it's shapewear that's comfortable
treat yourself to the best shape around
the market and save 20 off at
honeylove.com toast that's 20 off when
you use our exclusive link honeylove.com
toast
all right ready for our next story
yes Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling go to
the real world in the new Barbie trailer
so they dropped the trailer for The
Barbie Movie I've seen this actually you
saw the trailer no but I saw like him I
knew that they were in it I knew they
were doing it so there's been like a lot
of hoopla a lot of hype but we've gotten
like a few pictures we got some um
paparazzi photos of them filming in
Venice Beach on Rollerblades but now we
got an official trailer get your roller
blades ready we're going to Barbie land
the official full-length trailer debuted
for Barbie on Tuesday chose Margot
Robbie front and center as the famous
blonde which with a bunch of other
Barbies and Ken's the comedy from
director Greta Gerwig brings brings the
iconic Mattel toys to life starring
alongside Robbie and as Barbie is Ryan
Gosling as Ken her male companion what
do you think about that casting I think
it's great I have actually um a thought
that I think will be a hot take okay
because I saw the trailer and my
immediate thought was like the thing
about Barbie and Ken and why they're
like toxic dolls like if you want to get
into that it's like they're perfect you
know their bodies are perfect they don't
have wrinkles and so Margot Robbie
literally looks perfect she does not
have a stitch of makeup out of place
Ryan Gosling not to be so rude but like
I can say it because he's a man he looks
hella [__] old like he's got wrinkles
on his forehead and I'm just saying if
we want to be you know completely
accurate he looks a little old I'm sorry
and you know what it's about time
somebody says that about a man so I feel
good about that I feel good about saying
that I think that they looked good I do
agree that they probably could have
found somebody that was a little bit
more ken-like without making him be Ken
like or just give him Botox like his
face just looked wrinkly like I'm sorry
I didn't see that okay
um so the whole premise of the the movie
is that like they live in Barbie land
but Barbie and Ken um
end up in the real world and they have
to like survive when they've only been
living in Barbie land it looks really
cute I'm not really sure if the movie is
for adults or kids I'm 99 sure it's for
adults if it's Margot Robbie and
who is it Ryan Gosling right that's not
for kids it's not for kids right now
what's it rated right you know what I
feel like it may be in the trailer they
have the rating I was just like I was
watching something this looks so cute
but like Barbies are for kids but this
movie looks like it's for
adults
I'm not entirely sure
let me just um I'm gonna look it up
really quick I mean it's 100 for adults
you can look it up you think yeah yeah
like Barbies were like this is a
Nostalgia play right like it's foreign
for Millennials that played with Barbies
kids still play with Barbies yeah sure
I'm sure less
I'm just looking up the rating I just
want to actually be curious to know if
more kids play with Barbies today or
played with Barbies then no they do I
mean Barbies are really popular
especially since they finally made
Barbies like for everyone you know yeah
they have all different shapes sizes is
the Barbie movie gonna be rated R this
is not this is a common question
it's PG-13
makes sense so it is not for kids yeah R
would have been like bad Barbie like if
you've seen Bad Santa like they
obviously could have taken in that
direction snorting coke yeah or like
she's a prostitute
honestly yeah
no maybe it's like Barbie this is how we
would do R-rated Barbie she's living
this life perfect life in Barbie land
but she wants more and she's like she's
kind of Wanderlust she wants to
experience more things before she
settles down with Ken so she kind of
goes on like a rum Springer like they do
in the Amish and she goes to the real
world for her um her rum Springer and I
think it's just a rum Springer it's a
rum Springer trust me
I watched Breaking Amish it's a rum
Springer yay so she goes to the real
world for her rum Springer and she like
goes wild she's in New York City and she
goes to strip clubs and she buys drugs
and she makes out with girls and boys
and she flashes her titties and I don't
know where like the movie ends like does
she end up wanting to live in the rum
Springer or does it make her grateful
for I think in the end like she's ends
up in jail or something and she's like
oh I just really wish I was home with
Ken right now and she clicks her heels
three times and she ends up in with with
Ryan Gosling back in Barbie life my
movie sounds good it's a great movie The
only change that I would make is I'd
make it a little bit more like elf
because it really is it could be very
similar yeah Barbie gets dropped but all
of a sudden she like literally needs to
sell her body for cash and like the
movie starts super dark no that gets
dark it should be dark it's like Batman
the new Batman no it's not depressing
when all of a sudden it's it's really a
true uh what is the right term not
coming of age but like she goes from
these dark red switches Rags to Riches
yeah I like mine better
I guess they're both interesting I feel
like we've been talking so fast like
we're already on the fifth Story like
we're just like I'm coming a mile a
minute are we talking fast
I don't know
[Music]
hey rum Springer that's gonna be like my
new word you know Jackie and I always
like fixate on words like we learn a new
word
our new word is acrimonious by the way I
am realizing now that I'm taking a beat
I'm like I feel like we've been
sprinting I'm like Adderall yeah but
like that was good conversation it was
but like honestly people need to might
need to listen to this on half speed
we're going crazy we were
there's a lot of like Crossfire too I
know you shoot I should you shoot I
shoot you were kind of like cutting me
off I should you should I shoot
okay the fifth and final story though is
really what we brought you on for and I
don't even know if you know about more
of the aftermath there's like a lot of
drama with Iowa and LSU
I've seen I've seen by the way I'm fully
up to date okay but let me give you let
me read you up on everything so you know
who Angel race is right yes okay Angel
Reese calls Jill Biden's idea to invite
both LSU and Iowa to the White House
quote a joke
so wait sorry is Angel Reese the coach
No Angel Reese is the star player of
unless yes that I know so Dr Jill Biden
first lady has apparently decided
against inviting both women's teams for
them from the NCAA tournament
um after LSU star Angel Reese reacted
negatively to the idea on social media
so the first lady 71 who attended Sunday
night's game between Louisiana State
University and Iowa Hawkeyes proposed
the idea while speaking at the Colorado
State Capitol in Denver so after the
game she said so I know we'll have the
Champions come to the White House we
always do so we hope LSU will come you
know but I'm going to tell Joe Biden I
think Iowa should come too because they
played such a good game traditionally
only the winning team the national
champions receive an invitation to the
White House it's an honor and if Iowa
had also received an invitation it would
be the first time that both title game
teams were offered the opportunity
ESPN reported on Joe Biden's suggestion
shortly after
um and then that caught the attention of
Angel Reese from LSU
she shared the link to ESPN's story and
wrote in all caps a joke with three
laughing emojis and then the LSU guard
Alexis Morris also chimed in suggesting
that the teams celebrate their win with
former First Lady Michelle Obama instead
Rhys reshared
um Morris's tweet and wrote um that's
the Tweet so the uh
Alexis Morris tweeted Michelle Obama can
we LSU national champs come celebrate
our win at your house and then Angel
Reese quote tweeted it and was like yeah
that's the Tweet so let's just backtrack
okay
I kind of completely agree with Angel
Reese like it's not I I get why Dr Jill
wanted to invite Iowa like part of the
reason why so many people were invested
in this Saga is because of Caitlyn Clark
but I'm sorry that doesn't change the
rules and like yeah they won fair and
square like then we're all winners at
the White House that [__] sucks by
the way what kind of doctor is Doctor
Jill um like a PhD like Ross Geller
she's so fraud she's a teacher okay fine
now I'm just saying like might as well
be a dentist right DDS
um Angel Reese uh is 100 right here yeah
um and it's funny because I know we
started talking about it the only reason
that anybody watched that final was
because of Caitlyn Clark and the hyper
and that's a fact yeah the fact is
LSU
beat Iowa fair and square and sports is
about winning and losing yeah Sports is
not about thanks for coming that's so
true especially like competitive
professional sports college level for
it's actually so
demeaning almost it's very for for the
for the most televised women's sporting
event in history for the
uh losers
no for the president's wife to what are
they what do you call the president's
wife first lady first lady oh my God I
was like what do you call that FLOTUS
yes yes for the first lady to suggest
that all participants come no you're
taking that away from LSU like yeah no
Alex you deserves their their time to
shine very separately you've seen it
like across the board like Obama did it
with a bunch of athletes like Joe Biden
should invite Caitlin Clark and like
give her like a medal of honor or like
one of those like great achievement in
women's sports yeah like what they did
with Tiger Woods yeah later it's not
like LSU these girls like one fair and
square they must be so proud and like to
have like one of that's such a cool
honor like that's a once in a lifetime
thing to be invited to the White House
and like to have also the losers come
like no no absolute shame that's that's
not right but this tweet um from one of
the other players that angel Reese
retweeted now they want to go to
Michelle Obama's house like this is
becoming really contentious like them
not them pitting FLOTUS against FLOTUS
it's actually really interesting it's
also a great tweet yeah and uh and I
hope it happens who'd you rather party
with Michelle hands down Michelle's cool
no and they have like so much money in
like so many cool houses like I want to
go to their house I'd love to hang out
with Michelle Obama she seems like
cooling down to earth and she would
never suggest something like this no and
like I don't know I just don't want to
party with fake doctors like like God
forbid like something gets in my drink
Jill Biden's not gonna do anything like
the point of having a doctor is that she
can save my life like I don't want this
like fraud okay honestly like you were
doing good now you're gonna get us
canceled
um I just found this Saga to be so
interesting and I don't know I wonder if
Michelle Obama will throw her hat in the
ring I bet she doesn't want to make
things worse for Jill
but Michelle Obama didn't invite them
that could really that would be like
very contentious she could become as the
kids say the moment the moment yeah
Special Obama's a moment she could um so
those were the past five I really
appreciate you sitting down with me I
know how busy you are as a celebrity a
Founder a podcaster a CEO so to get you
for 40 minutes is such a privilege
oh there's nothing left like no more
like no more stories did you want to
talk about something else no no I meant
like
like nothing else you wanted to say
about me loving husband birthday maybe
you're a big dick oh my God sexy ass it
always goes towards objectifying yeah I
don't do that to you big jokes
we're just big jugs and big dicks yeah
by the way everyone hanging out with us
by the way if uh what's her name from
LSU Angel race Angel Reese if you get a
no for Michelle Obama and you get a no
from Jill Biden like you come hang with
us yeah come down to Florida we'll show
you a good time yeah it's great like at
the party come on the Pod I think I'll
call today's episode big jugs and big
dicks I think that's good for click bait
I think so too we have to keep people
like enticed yeah on their toes on their
toes on their toes I love you dearly
thank you so much for being here thanks
for having me and this is our last
episode until Friday because tomorrow
Begins the holiday of pesach also known
as Passover so no episode Wednesday and
Thursday we will be dropping content on
the patreon to keep you satiated and
yeah we love you guys so much everyone's
celebrating hope you have a great
Passover have fun at the seders don't
forget to lean recline
so have a good Passover we love you and
we'll see you on the next one we'll see
you on Friday thank you so much for
listening to the dose of Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories you need to know everybody
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
on Spotify
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you on Friday
bye